The excitement of straight guys at the idea of lesbians is a well known, and for many women, a deeply irritating phenomenon.
No, they aren't just waiting for a guy to join them. But underneath the arrogance, there's more interesting and more benevolent way to interpret the male fascination with lesbians.
Freud once remarked that the majority of men start off believing that their own mothers must be virgins.
A piece of primitive, unconscious nonsense they then project onto other women.
This creates a lot of guilt around sex. In adolescense,  women can seem the more reluctant party; as though sex were the man's dirty idea.
If lesbianism is then exciting, it's because it proves incontrovertibly that sex isn't just some primitive dirty male thing.
It's something that women want as badly and as intensely as men do.
So even if men happen to be excluded from this particular instance of female desire, they gain relief from seeing that they are clearly not the only ones who want sex in general.
A burden of guilt is thereby removed, which can spill over into irritating puppy-ish excitement.
But the real thrill for men isn't the fantasy that lesbians are going to sleep with them, it's the proof that women are just as interested in sex as they are.
Which to a lot of men, remains a remarkably novel and comforting bit of news.